Notice that there are three rotation angels on the three.js object. You can
rotate around the x, y, or z axis all together. If you're controlling a plane,
the x rotation is known as the pitch angle. Since it pitches the plane up and
down, the y angle is known as the yaw or head direction, since that's the
direction the plane heads. Z is the roll, how much you're rotating around the
axis of the plane itself. In some other fields these angles are called the x
roll, y roll and z roll. These angles are called Euler angles when used together
in this way. They're named after Leonhard Euler, a Swiss mathematician and
physicist who lived in the eighteenth century. He was one of the most prolific
mathematicians of all time. If you have ever run across the number e, that's
called Euler's number. Euler invented using the sigma sign for summation. Just
listing out his accomplishments would take a whole unit at least, but you get
the idea. There's a great quote from Euler that sums him up for me. When he lost
the use of his right eye, he said, now I will have less distraction. In
three.js, the Euler angels are applied to the model in the orders z, y, and x. I
should mention that this order can be different in different applications. For
example, the order z, x, z is seen in robotics. What happens if you rotate
around two or more of these axes? The short answer is that the frame of
reference changes for each rotation. This is actually easier to see than to
explain. Here I'm changing the x rotation. And you can see that the plane
pitches up and down. Now, applying the y rotation, notice that we're not
rotating around the world's y-axis. But rather, around a plane that is defined
by the x rotation. In other words, the y rotation is applied with respect to the
plane's frame of reference, not the world's. In fact, all the rotations are
applied with respect to the plane. The initial x rotation just happened to be
aligned with the world. The z rotation is also clearly changing with respect to
the plane's orientation, rolling it along its axis. Euler angles are handy for
flight simulators, robotic applications, and even mobile applications, as they
can be used to describe the orientation of the mobile device itself. However,
Euler angles can also run into limitations, such as the problem of Gimbal lock.
For example, say that I set the angle of rotation for the y-axis to 90 degrees.
You can now see that the x rotation and the z rotation have exactly the same
effect. We've lost a degree of freedom under these conditions, limiting how we
can move away from this orientation. I encourage you to play with the Euler
angles demo that follows and get a feel for the strengths and limitations of
this method of setting rotations. Definitely try setting the y angle to about 90
degrees to see Gimbal lock in action.